there's something about this it's like
whenever i look at world war ii whenever
i look at wars
it does seem very irrational to fight
but man
does it
seem somehow deeply human when the
people stand up and fight
there's something
uh
that if you know we talked about
progress
that feels like how progress is made
the people that stand and fight so let
me read the churchill speech
it's such
i so proud that we humans can stand up
to evil when the time is right i guess
here's the thing though think of what's
happening in xinjiang in china we have
we've appeased china
we've basically said you can just
do
really really really horrible things in
this region and we're you're too
powerful for us to do anything about it
and it's not worth it
and and there's nobody standing up and
making a churchill speech
or a the braveheart speech about
standing up for people of of xinjiang
when when what's happening is
um on you know in that in that in that
realm of what was happening in europe
and and that's happening in a lot of
places
um and then when we when when there is a
willingness to stand up
people there's a lot of opposition to
those you know people you know so there
were a lot of reasons for the invasion
of iraq
um for some it was humanitarian things
like
saddam hussein was one of the worst
tyrants of
the 20th century he was just doing some
really horrible things you know he'd
invaded kuwait he'd you know committed
domestic
attempted domestic genocide and all
sorts of repression and it was probably
a mistake to invade in spite so it's
important not just to select on the
cases where we stood up and to select on
the cases where that ended up working
out
uh in the sense of victory
right it's important to sort of try to
judge
not judge but just try to understand
these things in the context of
all the times we didn't
give that speech or when we did and then
it just went sideways well that's why
it's powerful when you're willing to
give your life for your principles
because most of the time
you get neither the principles
nor the life you get you die that's what
but that's why it's powerful we shall go
on to the end we shall fight in france
we shall fight on the seas and the
oceans we shall fight with growing
confidence and growing strength in the
air we shall defend our island whatever
the cost may be we shall fight on the
beaches we shall fight on the landing
grounds we shall fight in the fields and
in the streets
we shall fight in the hills we shall
never surrender
this is before hitler had any major loss
to anybody
that was a terrifying armada coming your
way we shall never surrender i just want
to give props
uh i want to give my respect as a human
being
uh to churchill to the british people
for standing up
to the ukrainian people for standing up
and for um and to the russian people
these are great people
that throughout history have stood up to
evil
you